hey ich bin natalie und diese woche
jetzt bei place to be stars & stories
von und mit queen of pop madonna model
kendall jenner place to be awards
gewinnerin marie nasemann einer
berlinerin die über nacht berühmt wurde
und vielen ungeschminkten stars
[Musik]
queen of pop und stilikone madonna
feierte zu ihrem geburtstag eine
ziemlich abgedrehte party auf jamaika
auf instagram teilte sie mehrere fotos
und videos auf denen man sie feiert und
mit bunten drinks in der hand sieht mit
dabei neben tochter lord auch ihr freund
aller malik mit dem tänzer hat sie jetzt
übrigens die zahlen ihres alters
gemeinsam die sechs und die 2 er ist 26
sie jetzt 62 wie egal der
altersunterschied ist sieht man beim
kuscheln und innigen tanzen madonna
winkt dabei ganz verliebt insgesamt
wirkt diese party für einen superstar
sehr bodenständig und bescheiden so
drehte sich madonna wohl sogar ihre
zigaretten selbst in dieser kleinen high
society blieb aber trotzdem alles im
rahmen
[Musik]
und nach einem jamaikanischen
geburtstagsständchen bedankte sie sich
wie es sich in corona zeiten gehört mit
dem ellenbogen
auch gruner like und mit noch mehr
sozialer distanzen die urlaubs postings
von model kendall jenner stadt mit
großer interesse war sie nur mit ihren
schwestern khloe und kylie sowie deren
kindern unterwegs und zeigte sich bei
einsamen ausritte am strand oder sexy
auf einem boot
viele deutsche stars leben aktuell eher
zurückgezogen so schreibt model & place
to be awards gewinnerin marie nasemann
ihr erstes eigenes buch
worum es gehen soll hat die 31 jährige
allerdings noch nicht verraten
wir sind schon gespannt wenn es dann
nächstes jahr scheint dagegen wissen wir
bei ex gzsz schauspielerin sila sahin
das jedem september ihr erstes kochbuch
silas orient küche raus bringt es soll
eine bunte mischung aus mittelmeer und
orient wenig fleisch und viel gemüse
werden
da bekommt man jetzt schon appetit
waffen zu einsamen stränden und lektüre
von büchern kommen wir jetzt zum
neuesten trend mehr natürlichkeit
[Musik]
in unseren inside seht ihr diese woche
warum sich immer mehr stars ungeschminkt
zeigen so präsentiert sich jennifer
lopez erst kürzlich morgens im
bademantel und ohne make up und die
natürlichkeit steht taylor gut auch ohne
stylistin kann man kaum glauben dass die
sängerin und schauspielerin schon 51
jahre alt ist die kommentare ihrer fans
sind durchweg positiv
ich wünschte mein morning face würde so
aussehen oder so wunderschön sind nur
einige komplimente die sie für das foto
erhält der post hat mittlerweile fast
2,5 millionen likes während sie für
dieses bild auf dem sie perfekt gestylt
ist nur 1,3 millionen likes erhalten hat
lady gaga bekannt für ihre extravaganten
lux hat inzwischen auch kein problem
mehr damit fotos zu posten auf denen sie
ungeschminkt ist die sängerin
präsentiert und letzter zeit immer öfter
ihr ungeschminktes gesicht hatte man
früher das gefühl dass sie sich hinter
einer maske versteckt reichen dem stars
monster heute ein pinker sport bh und
ein wenig sonne völlig aus um sich
wohlzufühlen ab auf events oder im
fernsehen heidi klum sieht immer perfekt
gestylt aus doch ein blick auf ihren
instagram account zeigt dass die
47-jährige privat gerne natürlich ist
und ohne make up genauso schön aussieht
wie auf den roten teppichen dieser welt
das liegt bestimmt auch an ihrem großen
glück in denen sie nach wie vor
unsterblich verliebt ist und das auch
gerne ihren fans mitteilt um als
schauspielerin oder musikerin bekannt zu
werden ist gutes aussehen meist nicht
irrelevant dass sowas ist für seine
oberflächlichkeit bekannt 2016
veröffentlichte sängerin alicia keys
einen text im online newsletter lenny
indem sie beschreibt wie sehr sie der
schönheitswahn in den vergangenen jahren
unter druck gesetzt habt sie entschied
sich dazu künftig auf einem make-up
freien look zu setzen und moderierte
2009 10 sogar die grammys ganz natürlich
alicia keys sei es allerdings auch
wichtig zu betonen dass es jedem selbst
überlassen ist und sie kein problem
damit hat wenn jemand sich schminken
möchte auch im für unseren luisa deller
die sich für themen wie politik
nachhaltigkeit und selbstliebe engagiert
zeigt sich auf instagram sehr gerne
ungeschminkt und natürlich in einem
ihrer letzten posting reagiert sie auf
einen user kommentar ob sie nie
geschminkt sein
luisa dennert hat dazu folgende meinung
besonders jetzt im sommer kommt sie doch
immer man das thema schminken ja nein
auf und ich finde das muss jedem
menschen selbst überlassen sein ob er
sich schminken möchte oder nicht ich
persönlich finde es sonst im sommer
entspannter sich nicht zu schminken weil
ich ja wenn ich schwitze dann nicht
merke dass mir irgendwas runterläuft
oder verläuft und wenn ich dann abends
ins bett gehe dann brauche ich nicht
irgendwie stunden um mich ab zu
schminken ich finde aber es ist wie
gesagt jedem selbst überlassen ob man
sich schminken möchte oder nicht und da
darf man nicht fair oder auch nicht
dafür beurteilt werden
und ja jungen menschen würde ich einfach
raten da einfach mal in sich hinein zu
fühlen ob man es gut findet und das mag
sich zu schminken oder auch eben nicht
und auf insgesamt kann man sich ja immer
ganz viel inspiration holen und auch da
muss man glaube ich überlegen er tut mir
das jetzt gut was ich da gerade sehe
oder nicht setzt mich dass unter druck
wenn ich in die schule gehe dass ich das
gefühl habe ich muss mich jetzt
schminken weil es alle anderen machen
oder mache ich das weil ich spaß daran
habe und weil ich es einfach schön finde
und zum schluss würde ich nochmal sagen
ganz ganz ganz ganz wichtig ist jeder
mensch ist ohne schminke noch viel
toller als mit schminke und ich glaube
das schönste an einem gesicht wenn es um
das thema schminke geht ist das eigene
lächeln
unsere inspiration auf dem weg kommt von
emiliana der 29 jährigen berlinerin die
über nacht weltweit berühmt wurde
[Musik]
bei instagram postet sie videos in denen
die gebürtige senegalese auf rollschuhen
tanzt und dabei unglaublich cool und
unbeschwert aussieht am 22 juni hatte um
dann einen 52 sekunden lang clip
hochgeladen den sängerin alicia keys
teilte und von stars wie top model
gisele bündchen kommentiert wurde
durch diese prominente unterstützung ist
der account der berlinerin innerhalb
kürzester zeit von 54.000 follower auf
inzwischen fast 800 tausend follower
angestiegen entdeckt hat um ihre
leidenschaft schon vor vielen jahren als
sie auf einen rollstuhl disco event ging
und sich sofort in das so genannte dem
skating verliebt hat unter james gating
versteht man ein afrikanisch
amerikanischen skating style mit einem
mix aus tanz hip hop und gymnastik heute
hat um ihr hobby zum beruf gemacht sie
gibt unterricht und organisiert roller
discos wir finden um ihm zuzuschauen
macht gute laune und fühlt sich nach
sommer an
das war es diese woche vom place to be
stars & stories wenn ihr noch mehr stars
& stories wollt dann folgt uns auf
instagram place to be
[Musik]
[Applaus]